[Music]
on this Monday night much needed rain in
fire ravaged Alberta Mother Nature's
reprieve bringing relief to Residents
and firefighters oh I hope she pours and
pours and pork plus what police say is
hampering Crews
the eu's mega fine against meta why
Facebook's parent company is being
penalized and what it's being ordered to
stop doing
unprecedented alcohol labeling law it's
absolutely appropriate the new health
warning being slapped on booze bottles
in Ireland and 90 years after one of
Canada's worst race riots it just makes
me weep when I think about it the new
play portraying a shameful chapter of
Toronto's history
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Sophie Louie good
evening and thanks for joining us this
smoke triggered by Alberta's wildfires
has sparked a special air quality
statement from many areas across the
province it is thick and people are
being asked to stay indoors but there is
some relief tonight the smoke covers
cooling effect along with some
desperately needed rain are welcomed by
firefighters who are trying to get the
upper hand Mother Nature may be helping
but the RCMP also has a warning about
people hindering the firefighting effort
nitu garcha is in Fox Creek with mornita
what's the situation like there
well Sophie Alberta Wildfire says there
was significant rainfall across the
region overnight and that has helped in
the fire fight but here in Fox Creek the
rain didn't start falling until this
afternoon and now fire officials say
there is some good news in terms of the
fight to contain the Wildfire that's
threatening this community
it's the rainfall residents have been
hoping for
but Mother Nature's help with the
firefight comes as police are seeking
charges against someone they say
hindered the effort to protect people
and properties we'll go Highway 16. well
on an RCMP ride-along through parts of
Yellowhead County you jump in there I'll
jump in here Constable Patrick Lambert
is renewing warnings to all drivers near
active wildfires as we continue down
down this path of uh you know road
closures and changes to the landscape in
many cases what we want to ensure is
when advisories alerts or orders are
given
people follow those he says over the
long weekend a man allegedly eluded a
checkpoint got stuck in mud and soon
after was surrounded by Wildfire
requiring Rescue by a forestry
helicopter if roads are blocked
and there's no designated detour
just wait patiently the incident
happened near Fox Creek where this
section of Highway 43 has now reopened
with power lines still smoldering crews
are working to repair the damage
visibility here is limited with thick
smoke blanketing the area it's been
tough it's hard on the lungs for sure
Alberta Wildfire says widespread rain in
the West Central parts of the province
has helped in the fight to contain
several priority wildfires in the region
Fox Creek though received less
precipitation
residents like Linda and Stephen who
were forced to flee are hopeful oh I
hope she pours and pours and porks oh of
course because of course we can go back
home we've had bad news solid for so
long let's hope this is good news for
for once I'm pretty excited
and while albertans are being told to
stay indoors because of the low air
quality fire officials say the cooling
effect from the smoke has also helped
lessen fire activity by creating a cover
from the Sun
now provincial officials say that some
air operations did have to be grounded
because of the Thick Smoke and the low
visibility and they will be monitoring
for potential lightning-caused fires so
there is a lot to keep an eye on Sophie
but in all officials say that this
system of rain that is finally coming
down is bringing some much needed relief
back to you definitely all right thanks
for that reporting in Foxborough Alberta
thank you nitu well the wildfires are
very much top of Mind in the Alberta
election campaign with just one week to
go before voters head to the polls
Danielle Smith and Rachel notley both
focusing their efforts tonight in
Calgary where the Smoky skies are a grim
reminder of the emergency situation The
Province faces Sarah often is in Calgary
which many believe will decide the
election outcome Sarah Sophie all day it
has been a hazy sky over Calgary perhaps
symbolic of the haze that many undecided
voters are still navigating after what
has been and aggressive negative a
campaign province-wide but particularly
here in Battleground Calgary where many
believe that this election will be won
or lost there are still several key
writings at play here and that point
particularly not lost on campaign
strategists both parties have been here
constantly with each now ramping up
their efforts and focusing on familiar
talking points and key issues for
calgarians first and foremost Rachel
notley and the NDP are hosting a rally
targeting trust and Danielle Smith's
judgment while the UCP is door knocking
on concerns over the ndp's fiscal policy
and proposed hike to the corporate tax
rate Calgary has long been tied to the
ups and downs of energy resources and
each party is now arguing for its vision
of the future against the backdrop of
wildfires and what promises to be
another hot Smoky Alberta summer the
liberal NDP Alliance has said Net Zero
by 2035 is the only path forward and
Rachel notley is Dublin down on that and
this province could not figure out how
to create energy jobs in an energy
Province to deal with our orphan well
situations so political divisions have
one more week to play out on front Lawns
and it will not be a surprise to see
this campaign Trail Circle back to
Calgary a few more times before it's
done Advanced voting starts on Tuesday
Sophie all right thanks for that Sarah
often in Calgary for us now to Europe
where data protection authorities have
slapped Facebook owner meta with a
record fine for privacy violations
ordering the tech giant to stop
transferring user data from the European
Union to the United States that fine
equates to a staggering 1.75 billion
dollars Canadian and that breaks the
previous record for a privacy fine of
almost 1.1 billion dollars handed out to
Amazon two years ago this ruling centers
around concerns U.S intelligence
agencies could access the personal data
of EU citizens and as Redmond Shannon
reports it won't be easy for meta to
implement the changes it needs to do
a decade ago this week intelligence
contractor Edward Snowden fled the
United States after publicly exposing
the depth of surveillance used by the
NSA the U.S National Security Agency the
shockwaves are still Rippling including
Monday's record-breaking fine handed out
to Facebook parent company meta for
violating stringent European privacy
laws we're happy that there is a
decision uh the penalty itself could
have been higher Austrian activist Max
Rems was inspired by snowden's
revelations to take legal action against
Facebook and how it transfers European
users data to the U.S where the NSA
could access it they tell the rest of
the world give us all your data we're
going to host it all in the U.S but
actually once your data is in the U.S
you have no rights whatsoever the ruling
also mandates that Facebook stops
sending data to the us and that it
deletes the last 10 years of user data
transfers a technical nightmare meta
claims it's being unfairly singled out
and will appeal its head of global
Affairs said the decision is flawed
unjustified and sets a dangerous
precedent for other companies experts
think meta will likely lose the appeal
and may have to adjust keeping European
data in Europe but foreign spy agencies
aren't limited by where physical servers
sit there may still be a possibility for
that data to be supported in the US by
the uh by the parent company and may be
retrieved also from the EU so it's very
difficult to have guarantees the US and
EU are working on new harmonized rules
but EU lawmakers have said they don't go
far enough we expect it will be
challenged at some point there is little
appetite in Washington to force Silicon
Valley to give any more ground despite
lawmakers grilling tick tocks CEO over
concerns about data collection in China
from American users the EU says meta
didn't adequately prioritize user
privacy and now it has to pay Redman
Shannon Global News London
a frightening but fake photo of an
explosion at the Pentagon made the
rounds briefly on Twitter today but not
before causing the stock market to dip
the image which we have chosen not to
show is believed to be AI generated it
was retweeted by several verified
accounts before the Arlington fire
department clarified that there had in
fact been no explosion and there was no
danger verified check marks can now be
purchased and are no longer a guarantee
a Twitter account is legitimate the
market dropped a quarter of a percent
but bounced back once the fake news was
debunked and Wall Street closed out the
date mixed as the standoff over the U.S
debt ceiling nears a critical deadline
and talks continue between Republicans
and President Joe Biden to reach a deal
by next week when America could default
on trillions of dollars in debt
potentially triggering a global
financial crisis Jackson Prasco now with
what's at stake
we're optimistic we may be able to make
some progress down to the wire
negotiators met again to try and avert
an economic catastrophe the consequence
for failing a pair of bills would be
that American people would have a real
kick in their economic well-being as a
matter of fact the rest of the world
would too the toughest issue remains
spending which Republicans want cut or
else they'll refuse to lift the cap on
U.S borrowing forcing an unprecedented
default on American debt I think we both
agree that we need to change the
directory that our debt is too large
with little more than a week left to
reach a deal President Joe Biden cut
short an overseas trip to return to
Washington he's increasingly open to
some kind of compromise proposing one
trillion dollars in spending cuts
without an agreement the treasury
secretary warns the government will run
out of money by June 1st I certainly
haven't changed my assessment so I think
that that's uh a hard deadline should
the U as default it would be unable to
pay for social programs make payments to
government workers or service trillions
of dollars in foreign held debt the
results of this would be catastrophic uh
economically that you'd you'd
immediately the estimates have been that
the gross national product might
contract over the following 12 months as
much as six or seven percent we need to
cut spending but the longer it takes to
reach an agreement the bigger the risks
markets are increasingly worried about
the what-ifs the U.S could see its
credit rating downgraded the longer the
stalemate lasts you know in my eyes
we're playing Russian roulette with the
United States credit and it shouldn't
even be an option for all the talk of
that June 1st deadline the reality is
much more Grim even if a deal is reached
it will still need to be passed by
Congress that's a process that could
take several days the longer it takes
for the whole thing to come together the
closer the U.S will come to plunging off
of that fiscal cliff
Sophie Jackson prosco in Washington for
us thanks Jackson tragedy strikes in
Guyana coming up the deadly fire that
tore through a school dormitory
plus Ireland's new Landmark labeling
laws for Booze and we have liftoff Saudi
Arabia's historic Mission into space
in the West Bank Israeli forces have
killed three Palestinian men during the
latest round of violence in the region
hundreds gathered for funerals for the
men identified as members of a
Palestinian militant group they were
killed in a large pre-dawn raid at a
refugee camp conducted by Israeli troops
Palestinian officials claim those troops
also blocked access for Medical Aid and
used bulldozers to demolish a number of
homes Israel's military says it found
and destroyed an explosives Lab at that
camp also confiscating weapons and
arresting three other men
in Guyana at least 19 children had been
killed in a fire in a school dormitory
overnight The Blaze broke out in a
secondary school housing students aged
12 to 18 most of the victims were
indigenous firefighters say the building
was completely engulfed in flames by the
time they arrived but they were able to
rescue about 20 students the cause of
the fire is being investigated
a Belarusian opposition blogger arrested
in 2021 after his flight was forced to
land was given a presidential pardon
today according to the state news agency
Roman protozoic had been sentenced to
eight years in prison for inciting
terrorism and plotting to seize power he
ran a messaging app widely used in Mass
protests against the disputed
presidential election outcome in 2020
authoritarian President Alexander
lukashenka won a sixth term in office
the protests which lasted months were
the longest and largest anti-government
demonstrations since he took power in
1994. potosevic says he is incredibly
grateful for the pardon
[__]
policy push ahead reactions to Ireland's
introduction of an alcohol labeling law
[Music]
Ireland has become the first country in
the world to approve Comprehensive
Health warnings on alcohol products the
new rules were signed into law today the
Irish Cancer Society has been lobbying
for them for decades with alcohol
consumption linked to cancer and other
serious health conditions Crystal
commencing Reports on the changes and
the messages they might send
[Music]
with the highest rate of cancer in
Europe health warning labels have been
approved for alcohol products in Ireland
the health Minister signed off on the
regulations Monday morning ensuring
alcohol content calories and the risks
of liver disease and Cancers are clearly
spelled out for consumers around 4 in 10
cancers are preventable and we want as
many preventable Cancers and to be
stopped in their tracks
alcohol is a group one carcinogen and
can cause at least seven types of cancer
it's what's known as a modifiable risk
factor the less you drink the lower your
risk alcohol is also associated with
liver and cardiovascular disease but
Rachel Morrow says risks are often
unknown or overlooked words like Nani
State have been used
um in the discussions up to this point
and really it's not making the decision
for people it's just giving people
information so that they can make the
decision themselves well Europe may be
perceived as having more of a drinking
culture about a third of the Canadian
population consumes alcohol and on this
Victoria Day long weekend also known as
May 2-4 as in a 24 case of beer we ask
Canadians about the risks associated
with drinking and the idea of warning
labels I just don't think a lot of
people will read it to be honest
especially at the drinking I like I feel
alcohol is not good for health a final
guidance report was published in January
on alcohol and health by the Canadian
Center on substance use and addictions
it noted a moderate risk of negative
health effects for those who consume
three to six drinks per week if you see
someone say your risk of cancer
increases 50 percent when you drink four
drinks a week that sounds really pretty
scary but if your risk of cancer is
really low to start with then there
becomes this Balancing Act how science
is Professor Dan Malek calls the labels
an overreach saying they don't take into
account the benefits like socialization
Irish Advocates say it's about
preventing cancer and want others to
follow their lead we very much hope that
other countries will hear the message
and that we're sending which is that
public health does Trump commercial
interests the new regulations in Ireland
won't come into effect until 2026.
Crystal gemancing Global News London
[Music]
highlighting hate next the play
educating Canadians about one of
Toronto's worst riots over race
[Music]
the second all private astronaut team on
its way to the International Space
Station including the first two visitors
from Saudi Arabia to ride a rocket in 38
years
one is the country's first woman to go
to space a breast cancer researcher they
docked at the ISS today and will be
there for 10 days before returning to
Earth
on this holiday Monday you'll probably
see people flock to a baseball diamond
to play some ball one particular Park in
Toronto though stands out for all the
wrong reasons it's where one of Canada's
worst riots over race erupted almost a
century ago Erica Vela shows us how one
family wants to educate a new generation
about this Grim part of Toronto's past
on a warm holiday Monday Toronto's
Christy Pitts Park is filled with people
there's laughter Leisure and Long
Shadows in the afternoon sun Sam
Rosenthal can't help being struck by it
and what a contrast it is to a chapter
in Toronto's history that erupted here
at a baseball game almost 90 years ago
it was a championship game and
um some
anti-semitic Neo-Nazi youths unveiled a
large ban or a swastika at the end of
the ball game and that resulted in some
of the players charging to take down the
flag before it was over more than ten
thousand people were involved in the
riot I mean it was just a terrible waste
Joe rosenthal's family owned a nearby
shop and he remembers the anti-semitic
violence of the era if you can imagine a
thing like that you'd go on the street
in the evening and people were pounding
each other I mean it just makes me weep
his memories inspired a new production
by unique local theater Collective run
by his son Sam Rosenthal the Hogtown
collectives producing an immersive play
set right here in the very place where
the riot unfolded
Hitler with this kind of site-specific
theater I mean this is our theater
and audience members are standing as
close to the actors as I am standing to
you so it's a very visceral experience
nationally hate crimes are on the rise
with overt intolerance acutely targeting
religion where we're seeing you know
Rising
um anti-Semitism other forms of racism
discrimination
um increased polarization right like if
we can understand sort of some of these
histories and have these sort of shared
understandings of what's important about
those lessons too I think it can go a
really long way at 88 years old seeing
the production come to life gives Joe
Rosenthal hope this is part of our
history putting a spotlight on the hate
he witnessed so it won't ever be
forgotten
Global News Toronto
and that's global national for this
Monday I'm Sophie Louis we want to wish
you a happy Victoria Day so tonight's
your Canada is the 123rd annual Victoria
Day Parade in the city named after Queen
Victoria who reigned from 1837 to 1901.
we hope you've been able to spend some
time with family and loved ones this May
long weekend thanks for watching tonight
Donna Friesen will be back at the anchor
desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you